clearing your throat after you walk out
in front of the curtain instead of
before
come on marge you knew the game fling
that flynn before you step out
halloween is a very strange holiday
personally
i don't understand it you wear other
people's faces and demand candy from
your neighbors
what's there to understand scary episode
opens on a graveyard cliche
episode not created by bat graining but
it was too late
end of story having to say end of story
after your story finishes is a clear
sign your story was lame if your
audience doesn't know when it's over
you're not doing your job right
that's it that's that's it quit throwing
your garbage into our dimension
garbage that was a delicious orange at
the very least the note should read the
chewy exterior was terrible but the
inside was delicious
send more all right but if anything
happens
anything like your first born choking on
a floating lamp cord
or maybe a kitchen with bleeding walls
those kinds of anything
the stabsons all seem like they want to
kill each other but they sure aren't
trying very hard
homer's certainly within swinging
distance and could catch maggie easily
where's the effort
spreading mayonnaise with a bread
cutting knife also spelling mayonnaise
with one end
also also mayonnaise this is a great
conceit for an annual halloween
anthology episode kids telling scary
stories in a treehouse works so well
and i'm sure they won't immediately
abandon the concept and have the
treehouse of horror episodes never
include an actual treehouse again
mafia street af apron i don't get it and
why is this tree purple
it's not like the animators don't know
how to color trees brown there's one
right there
cool man the fact that the animators
avoided showing all of bart's hair
singed off only furthers my belief that
the top of his skull
is zigzag shaped and not his hair this
episode is truly not for the squeamish
your burgers are getting cold got holy
moly
burgers after that explosion anything
near the grill would be instantly turned
to coal
also the only thing scarier than the
fact that the shadows of the ufo have
made this burger a deep shade of mold
green
is that homer already took a bite out of
that burger and now it's whole again
by an astonishing coincidence both of
our languages are exactly the same
that is an astonishing coincidence and a
really funny joke but also a true hum
dinger of a coincidence but that's kind
of the joke
dang it where's the sins rule book let's
see schools of transportation
difference between irony and satire ah
here it is if something is both truly
coincidental but also really funny
because the coincidence itself
is the joke do not sin unless it's an
episode of the simpsons then go for it
because really you aren't going to get
many opportunities
well thank you very much mister to
pronounce it correctly
i would have to pull out your tongue but
kang just told us that by an astonishing
coincidence their language and english
were the same
so why would he have a name that is
unpronounceable fried shrimp
eating fried shrimp with a fork also the
eating sounds in this episode are
absolute torture
combine the simpsons slurps with the
sonic slobbering of the kang gang and
someone owes me 90 dollars for making me
shatter my headphones against the wall
on this cable system we receive over 1
million channels from the furthest
reaches of the galaxy
considering running cables to an
intergalactic ship traveling through
space would be a tough go i'm guessing
you mean satellite
anyone from a species that has mastered
intergalactic travel raise your hand
just pointing out here that that is a
tentacle so
wait there's still more space dust on
here
sure it's a funny series of jokes but
how did they only blow the dust off such
specific parts of the book
i haven't seen precision blow jobs like
this since i had to research the sexual
olympics for a recent spongebob sin
script
they thought we were going to eat them
well yeah
cause all the weighing and the maniacal
laughing and such
what was that all about well if you
wanted to make sarak the preparer cry
mission accomplished but you said
earlier you had a name that couldn't
even be pronounced
wait was that a different alien at the
very least this is a sin for not being
clear with your alien character work
once upon a midnight dreary
while i pondered weak and weary
narrating
i mean sure it's james earl jones but if
i make an exception for him
next thing you know i'm getting a phone
call from morgan freeman's people and
then it just becomes a thing
so it's really easier for everyone this
way ah
distinctly i remember it was in the
bleak december
that's right this segment is entirely
posed the raven poem
brought to you by the hey it's public
domain so why not association of easy
content
you know what would have been scarier
than nothing what anything
alberto would be excellent at posins
don't like crispy shawn and shaven
though
i said a journal craven man
there must be some tensions about to
happen in the future because this
segment is thoroughly
pretentious what you don't like
pretentious wordplay fine go ahead and
be
contentious also since when does homer
simpson know the definition of words
like
shawn or craven or and
these books are just regular old edgar
allen poe titles instead of pun titles
and honestly simpsons i expect more from
you
take thy beak from out my heart and take
thy
farm from off my door quoth the raven
never more
was i just taken it to an alternate
dimension where homer's performance of
an eap poem was genuinely moving
look if you're a simpsons fan this
telling of the raven with james earl
jones narrating is the definitive
version
it gives me chills every time i watch it
no matter how much of a jerk i am to it
damn maggie has the grip of a coconut
crab and she's just a baby
if she doesn't grow up to free solo el
capitan or star in an over-the-top
sequel then what really is the point of
anything
vogue on poetry is widely accepted
as the third worst in the universe
people be like oh is there a comment on
the video when it's just posted
fans be like i'm a member motherfu you
can be a [ __ ] member too get
videos early extra videos bonus podcasts
swag discounts and more click the
patreon link in the description or at
cinemasins.com to take your sin to the
next level
[Music]
and a dollar for yourself i said a
dollar [ __ ]
i can feel an evil presence in this
house evil
like it's the fruits of the devil is
this haunted room
actually stretching
[Music]
this last question who is this you
didn't tell me it was built
on an indian burial ground you're gonna
have to call the
united nations and get a [ __ ] binding
resolution to keep me from
destroying you well that's not my
recollection okay
flaming dragon face first take a big
step back
and literally [ __ ] your own face yeah
well
all right goodbye let's get some
applesauce out here for these pork chops
pork chops and apple sauce
and that swell i have a feeling you'll
be the
guests of honor mania golem